[Music]
this idea that but you all not you all
but now it is well Biden's it one poll
showed him at 33 the average is 47 44 45
I don't believe the polls I'm not quite
sure what the disconnect is between the
accomplishments of the administration
and this Congress and some of the you
know the polling and the ongoing hand
ringing Mr President
short
[Music]
well disconnect is that inflation is
rising and interest rates are going up
and people are feeling it it seems if
you look at the latest Quinnipiac poll
the president's job approval rating
stands at 33 percent if you break that
down Hispanics are at approval of 26
Independence 26 percent ages 18 to 34 21
the RCP Real Clear Politics average
direction of the country 27 percent say
right direction wrong track 64.9 and the
average on the economy for the approval
36 percent this is an average of recent
polls uh President Biden on the economy
those numbers are not good heading into
a midterm election season let's bring in
our panel Guy Benson political editor at
townhall.com host of The Guy Benson show
on Fox News Radio Leslie Marshall
Democratic strategist and syndicated
radio host Hugh Hewitt Hugh uh what do
you think about what the
administration's saying and doing in
reaction to some of these numbers well
the reality of the inflation number
Brett and the appearance of the
president are colliding and now it's a
question of what sinks faster the
president's approval or the musk uh the
Russian warship that went to the bottom
today guy tweeted out earlier today that
if you look at those numbers you just
put up it's the youngsters the 18 to 34
year olds that are hemorrhaging Latino
men as well but the youngsters and if
you think about an 18 year old voter who
doesn't much care for the opinions of
his 38 year old parents or his 58 year
old grandparents when they get up to
their 78 year old great-grandparents
they lose confidence and the president's
frail appearance and the reality of
eight and a half percent inflation is
just slaughtering his approval rating
and rightly so because there are many
things he could do that he doesn't and
therefore the the price the Democrats
will pay in November is going to be
steep
Leslie our friend Tom Bevin at
RealClearPolitics uh you know we're all
a little cynical at times but Tom tweets
out president prediction Biden's
approval rating uh is so low with 18 to
34 year olds he will have no choice but
to forgive a huge chunk of student loan
debt after Labor Day to try to help Dems
avoid complete disaster in November
by that I like Tom and I don't buy the
reason for it I mean student loan was
something a student loans was something
that the progressive faction of my party
wanted and you know you might and not
just that the voters of the democratic
party and not just Democratic party but
students the youth out there and that is
the number that concerns me I must say
Brett a couple independent uh and youth
voters and then if we break it down to
Suburban voters who are Independents and
among the youth that 18 to 21 year olds
that that concerns me look my party has
90 days to turn this around I know what
history has shown when it comes to
whoever's in power and what happens in
the house and how many seats you lose I
know I think we talked the other day
about biblical proportions and I
certainly don't want to see that
um you know but I think a lot of
Americans you know are going to go with
what they feel and it doesn't matter
who's in power they're going to blame
somebody and they're going to blame the
party in power even though inflation uh
to jensaki's point earlier is
multifaceted the government does have
some blame Federal Reserve has a lot of
control in they were very passive and
they should have many people were saying
uh economists were saying raise interest
rates before this uh in addition to that
we have corporations and and then of
course we have the pandemic and now you
add Russia Ukraine to the mix but we as
consumers I know I'm going to get a lot
of flack for this okay when I was a
little girl I remember picking up a
little teacup and my grandmother said
made in China That's junk put it down
and we as consumers need to really try
and buy American more and that will push
these corporations to stop Outsourcing
as much and to produce more American
Goods here that are going to be better
made and then we're supporting people
here that are making those products
rather than supporting people in China
making those products I doubt you'll get
a lot of pushback actually Leslie um guy
Associated Press thinking small Biden
scrounges for ways to break through all
the policies button is touting will have
direct impact on American lives but they
also fall far short of goals that Biden
set for himself when taking office taken
together they show how the White House
is trying to regain momentum at time
when Biden is under pressure to
recalibrate his Ambitions what never
really I never really understood guys
when he came in and all the Articles
were Biden is going to be the next FDR
even with these majorities that were so
small in the house and the Senate he was
going to suddenly have these big ideas
that came across the finish line and it
never happened
well to use a sports analogy you'll
sometimes hear about a team reading
their own clippings reading their own
press starting to believe it and then
cutting corners and failing that's what
happened here Biden believed his own
press he liked this notion of being the
next FDR maybe I can be more
consequential than Barack Obama let me
try it and it's been a big failure and
the fact that they're trotting Out Lines
like Putin's price hike to blame
virtually everything on that anything
but him I don't really have the energy
even to refute it every day because it
just isn't working right if it were
actually gaining some currency of the
American people perhaps I'd be more
concerned but it's not and I would just
direct you to a piece today in the New
York Times Stephen Ratner major
Economist under the Obama Administration
this is a democratic Economist who
looked at the situation right now he's
worried about a recession heading toward
2024 and he points to the inflation
problem right now and he says this is
quoting this is the price we pay for
poor economic policies delivered by the
White House by the Congress and by the
Federal Reserve and he calls the 1.9
trillion dollar rescue act exclusively
passed by democrats quote
an extraordinary policy mistake that
will go down in history that's an Obama
Economist just speaking the truth Biden
can talk about Putin until he's blue in
the face within the context of inflation
most voters aren't buying it
yeah Mark Patton a former Clinton
adviser says he sees a tornado against
Democrats in the midterms if these
numbers continue and he thinks they will
all right Hugh last thing I want to just
get you real quick on on Twitter Elon
Musk just tweeted out this if current
Twitter board takes actions contrary to
shareholder interests they would be
breaching their fiduciary duty the
liability they would thereby assume
would be Titanic in scale this is quite
something to watch Real Time tweet by
tweet here on the one side there's the
Panic on the left which is amusing but
on the other side the reality is what
Elon Musk just said corporations owe a
fiduciary duty to their shareholders to
maximize value he's put a very good
offer on the table if they don't come up
with a better one they will be flooded
rightly with lawsuits but it is both a
social and economic story but he is
right on the law shareholders own the
company and the board must act in
responsible fashion with care towards
Elon Musk asks offer and I hope they do
fascinating to watch panel as always
thank you hi winner Brian Kilmeade I
want you to do me a favor I want you to
click to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page this is the only way that I
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now